so I don't know if it's ever gonna be
completely possible to be 100%
sustainable I think you can start off by
not ordering as many clothes off the
internet and no one needs that many
clothes I think ultimately no it can't
be sustainable because everything is
going to have an impact of types but
what we can do is actually radically
reduce the impact that it's having fast
fashion can be described as clothes that
come out every single week in order to
satisfy the consumers needs and once and
as we're finding out it's incredibly bad
for the environment we live in a world
of Instagram where there's just images
every second of the day just being
pumped onto your feed and I think that
when it comes to clothes this kind of
creates this excitement in the consumer
where they constantly need more
[Music]
I think particularly in the United
Kingdom we have a problem with fast
fashion and very much profit driven
fashion industry ever wanting cheaper
and more affordable more rapid
turnaround types of clothing
something might be half as cheap but if
it lasts for only 25% at the time it's a
false economy garments are made for
lower quality which means that they're
worn less and then actually ultimately
thrown away into landfill or
incineration and all of this is very bad
for dwindling natural resources on this
planet just like diversity being
sustainable is a real buzzword right now
and a lot of companies are jumping on
that bandwagon because it makes them
look good it makes the consumer feel
that they're doing something good when
they buy a product as well one hand the
fashion industry has been very
irresponsible in the pursuit of that
always having new looks and new trends
and celebrating obsolescence some people
might argue but also with that has come
very rapid processing ability and there
the opportunity is to embrace these new
fibers new processes new more
environmentally responsible technologies
which actually will make for a more
sustainable future for us all certainly
some of the more environmentally salma
tools are more expensive but
increasingly as their popularity grows
there are actual the cost of the five
and the manufacture will actually come
in line with other traditional fibres
I'd like to think that the UK has
pioneered some of the most radical and
innovative areas of fashion both in
production and stylistically and the
opportunity now lies with us to do the
same and become global leaders in
responsible and accountable fashion - so
I definitely think companies need to be
transparent when it comes to how they
recycle their clothes I think that they
owe it to us and I think they owe it to
the environment as well
first of all think about it do you want
it or do you actually need it try and
discern between those different states
of mind and if you do absolutely need
something really consider what it is
that you're buying where it's from what
it's made from here are some of my top
tips on how to make your wardrobe more
sustainable wash your clothes less often
the average laundry cycle releases
thousands of tiny plastic fragments into
the waterways donate sell or swap
unwanted clothes before you purchase
something make sure that you can really
commit to wearing it at least 30 times
dressing sustainably does not mean that
you have to compromise on style the
honest truth is that actually fashion is
happening and will continue happening so
this might actually prompt more creative
explorations of the space more
responsible accountable types of design
and consuming potentially into the
digital or a virtual the fantastic thing
about the problem with clothing is we're
all part of the problem that we're also
all part of the solution
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon